criminals running wild this weekend in
many cities illegal street Racers taking
over a major intersection in Austin
Texas and Performing dangerous stunts
that came really close to hitting people
in the crowd police there completely
outnumbered to stop it in a large mob
surrounding and shooting fireworks at
one squad car the wild scene left for
one officer hurt and several police cars
damaged Austin council members say the
defund the police movement is to blame
and one of the attendees isn't worried
about the consequences
it is dangerous
can be dangerous once you start going in
and start doing things that you're not
really supposed to do then it is
dangerous what's your sorry to that
police officer that got hurt I mean he
should have just stayed in his own lane
are you ever scared that you are gonna
get arrested or something you know
you're gonna have like a felony charge
on you because of this
you know like I said they can't catch us
and as police deal with understaffing we
are once again reminded how dangerous
the job is the police catching the
cold-blooded killer who shot dead a
Temple University officer and using the
Fallen officer's handcuffs then to
arrest him that officer is Christopher
Fitzgerald he was a married father of
four and the son of a former police
chief and Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
trying to support law enforcement with a
pro-police tour in democrat-led cities
DeSantis thinks he knows exactly what is
behind the lawlessness it's important to
admit that these left-wing policies have
failed they've empowered criminals
they've put the public at risk they put
law enforcement officers at risk and so
I think that this this experiment has
concluded and we need to move in the
direction where across the board from
sea to shining sea we have a commitment
to respect for law enforcement and for
Law and Order all right well okay let's
go to our resident Texan for any updates
the what happened in Austin has actually
happened in many other cities across the
country that's true you you have all I'm
sure heard the the saying that it's
become somewhat popular over the last
five years that
um weak men create Hard Times Hard Times
create strong men strong men in turn
create easy times giving rise once again
to weak men Austin is a great example of
this you have the former mayor and Steve
Adler you have this Councilman Greg
cassar who are part of the let's defund
it to the tune of one-third of the
police budget this this leads although
they tried to refund it one year later
the police left in droves they haven't
been able to rehire to the levels that
is necessary this leads to moments like
this and it is true like you said in
Austin's near and dear to my heart I
lived there for three years it was an
incredible town it's headed down the
path of San Francisco it will be lost I
hope the entire State can protect itself
from turning into California but this
city unfortunately is symbolic of
something that's happening across this
nation where bad policies create bad
culture and then you get a bad town uh
Greg one of the police city council
members in Austin tried to call 9-1-1
and was on hold for 28 minutes
it goes back to one word that you
mentioned outnumbered right it's like
the pandemic kind of snapped the tether
between lawfulness and behavior and it
goes back to just fewer cops and not
just fewer cops but just fewer people in
general on the street which can kind of
keep the peace uh there's nothing more
vulnerable really than an empty Street
you know I'd rather be on a road with a
hundred crazy people then be alone with
myself
but also if you've noticed when you're
talking about this stuff and it may and
we run the risk of sounding like a bunch
of old fogies like these kids in their
zooped up cars because this has been
going on since the 50s right drag racing
and stuff like that but something else
is going on here it seems like all of
the assailants and a lot of these crimes
that we're covering are a lot younger
than they have been and they've been
recidivists like 16 17 year old kids and
gangs who've been doing stuff for a
while why do minors and I know what the
answer is why do minors have more rights
than us
like you know what we didn't even
mention the name of the kid that killed
the the police officer maybe because how
old is he 18 year old miles Pfeiffer
yeah he's 18. but I mean you know I
think it's time for prison reform reform
right we went too far we got to go back
no one's bothering to Cuff these miners
because they know they're going to get
out because there's a lack of
consequences so I think it's time to
create real consequences for kids and
don't leave them exempt from from our
rules of society because they happen to
be younger I don't know what you do
about that but if you're a dangerous
Society I don't care if you're 15 or 25
I know I'm in the minority but I would
lock you well sometimes you give provide
the perfect segue oh good and you just
have because Governor Ron DeSantis
talked about some reform reform earlier
today watch animal get the judge's
reaction in this country because we just
saw what happened to this police officer
in Philadelphia you know if these
criminals Target and they assassinate a
police officer they should get the death
penalty damn right
damn right look you know when you talk
about it these young kids who feel
empowered they're saying things like you
know sorry the police officers got hurt
but he should have stayed in his own
lane you know and they can't catch us
you know what we created these monsters
we have allowed them to get away with it
we as a society are allowing Anarchy to
take over on our streets and what
happens is when these kids get together
to do what they call drifting or Donuts
they'll go up one intersection check to
make sure there's no cops over the next
mile or so on and if there are they'll
go to another intersection they actually
you know publicize where they're going
to go on what they're going to do now
they take over these intersections and
they don't care what the injury is and
then they say the police can't catch us
and the police can't because they've got
these souped-up cars that the police
can't catch but I'm assuming they've got
the plate numbers on these cars so that
they can go after to them but who knows
who's actually driving the the cars now
you know what the problem is with these
young kids we've raised the age we raise
the age in this era of you know social
justice nonsense which makes no sense
you violate the law you go to jail it's
really as simple as that we've given
them criminal privilege they know
they've got criminal privilege they're
empowered and the irony of all of this
is that they are playing by the rules
and the rules today are no bail
you're not going to be able to catch us
and even if you do catch us I'm going to
get away with it and I'm just and these
are 16 17 years old now wait till
they're 25 30 years old that's a society
that we've got waiting for us it's a
mess
Jessica last word
I don't know if kids that are
perpetrating these crimes are saying you
know I've heard that Alvin Bragg is
really soft on crime I think that
Society is just wildly out of control
and it was really exacerbated by the
pandemic kids who were Suddenly at home
for school are just dropping out of
school running around and this was
happening in cities all over the country
um
I think that your point when you set it
on hold with the 90 the 911 call center
for 28 minutes is really important and
all of us were struck when we actually
heard the Paul Pelosi call right how
well Paul Pelosi actually handled it
right how clearly he was signaling to
the 9-1-1 caller that he was a person of
importance that he was in trouble and
the person didn't pick up on it at all
so that was someone who has in those
moments one of the most important jobs
in the world right like you have the
potential to stop a crime right by
releasing sending the police out there
right away and so if we can't get people
in the jobs or if we have people in the
jobs who are not qualified to do them
how can we run a civil society It seems
impossible so I don't think kids know
who Elvin Bragg is but I think they can
respond to a culture created by Alvin
Bragg there's no question and and Greg I
don't know if I've just been feeling old
lately but I am sympathetic to what you
said about not feeling like a
fuddy-duddy and I was telling myself
that you know after Sam Smith dressed up
like the demon yeah at the Grammys and I
thought okay well don't just be an old
fuddy-duty but then I said no no it's
okay to draw line at the Devil it's okay
you're not approved if you say
Satan that's where I draw my line and
with kids I draw them online at homicide
I was I was remembering back in uh so my
mom and Aunt Patty Sue APS they grew up
in Rawlins Wyoming and I I couldn't
remember the term but they reminded me
it's called dragging Main and they
started Jay's driving and you would
drive up Maine and then you'd come back
down yes hang out in the Safeway parking
lot and then you do it again because
that was the entertainment that seems
like good clean fun compared to this but
I do feel kind of old yeah I do too I do
too but we're not old we are moving
right along up next
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now